wer bekommt nämlich gerade die nachricht
ist wir jetzt sehr schnell mal nach
afghanistan schauen wollen dort ist
nämlich unser kollege paul ronzheimer
hinter ihm die taliban paul ist es sehr
schwer immer jetzt mit dir zu sprechen
nach afghanistan rein du bist einer der
wenigen journalisten der dort ist in
kabul verstehst an einem checkpoint bei
erklären sie einmal die situation bei
dir
der patrizier gerade von dem ehemaligen
bildungsministerium und hier hinter mir
der militärtransporter man sind
natürlich auch wieder die frage und wie
beim männer ihren eingehen denn das
bildungsministerium wir uns nämlich so
dass auch gerade bekannt geworden ist
und das ist was der klar gewesen dass
künftig in afghanistan ist keine
lehrerin mehr geben soll das sozusagen
frauen ausgesperrt werden aus den
schulen dass die größte frage was
passiert dann auch mit den mädchen
dürfen die noch zur schule gehen da
sagen
ja im einzelnen mädchenschulen aber
bislang gibt es diese getrennten schulen
also nicht also dieser noch down dieses
was sozusagen öffentlich
wird und immer öffentlicher wird zeigt
sich auch in diesen stunden das heißt
das noch mal ganz schnell einordnen das
sind ja tatsächlich news die du in die
welt bringt im moment dort aus kabul us
der gefährlichsten hauptstadt der welt
das war bis vor kurzem bis vor wenigen
tagen ein bildungsministerium vor dem du
gerade stehst und das wird jetzt
innerhalb weniger tage zum jahr nicht
bildungsministerium gemacht durch die
taliban
ja so kann man das sagen ja es ist so
dass wir hier erleben ganz viele
militärs einfahren gerade mehrere
motorräder gesehen auf den taliban waren
die hier sofort durchqueren konnten alle
anderen und scharf kontrollieren wir
wissen ja auch dass ganz viele ehemalige
angestellte zum beispiel die serie nicht
mehr zur arbeit erscheint war die angst
haben flüchten weil sich zu hause
verstecken und das was am ende auf dem
lehrplan steht hier in afghanistan das
entscheiden die taliban das entscheidet
sollte man die gebiete zu sagen das sind
die wachen dieses ministeriums die immer
noch die reinen kosten die sie lassen
wollen du beschreibst das was da hinter
dir vorgeht paul nehmen uns da mal ein
bisschen mit wer sind diese männer genau
was ist ihre aufgabe
und wie gehen sie da jetzt genau vor
dem sitz der verdi sind männer genau
sind ich habe noch nicht nach ihrem
namen gefragt muss ich sagen weil sie
doch ein bisschen furchteinflößend sind
in ihrer montur gerade davor die sind
dafür da checken wer hier ein pferd wäre
sozusagen durch die schranke darf in das
ministerium gehören von unseren kontakt
neben dass weniger mitarbeiter in diesen
ministerien entschieden sind eben aus
angst ich habe gerade gesehen wie hier
auch menschen weggeschickt wurden
interessant ist zum beispiel ein
motorrad gerade vorbeifahren an die
interessant ist dass uns die ihn denken
die direkt als taliban-kämpfer zu
erkennen sind in ihrer montur auch
insbesondere auf ihrem motorrad die
dürfen sofort rein und die andere alle
anderen werden die scharf kontrolliert
jetzt hast du uns auch in den
vergangenen stunden schon berichtet von
langen schlangen vor den banken menschen
die in ihrer not jetzt es gibt langsam
lebensmittelknappheit in kabul hast du
uns berichtet wir haben schon bilder
gesehen verzweifelte menschen vor
essensausgaben und jetzt menschen die
einfach an die geld heranwollen geld
abheben wollen und dann eben in langen
schlangen warten und dort auch dort in
den schlangen passen die taliban auf das
alles super diszipliniert super geordnet
ab geht und wenn man sich da an die
regeln hält gibt es drakonische strafen
zur iss ist wir haben live sehen können
wie einer der taliban einem derjenigen
der dort an der bank stand eine unter
grauem hut und da ist es noch die
freundlichste strafen kann man sagen wie
hier von den taliban gehören aus
verschiedenen regionen das bereits damit
begonnen wurde eben die scharia
anzuwenden
auch heute hinzurichten all das was er
angekündigt wurde das hat hier zumindest
in kabul bislang nicht im großen stil
stattgefunden
gerade die leitung nach hervorragenden
gebrochen pause ganz klar wieder zurück
will setzt nochmal an jetzt kann ich
wieder verstehen es gab kurze technische
störung ja ja das ist hier natürlich
auch mit den leitungen ein hin und her
und dem netz viele haben auch angst vor
einem stromausfall vertrieb weil die
taliban die rechnungen nicht überwinden
konnten die internet domain rechnung
bislang also dass wir auch noch ein
großes thema ich habe gesagt dass
langsam sozusagen diese vorboten
einsetzen was hier passieren können wir
hören immer mehr berichte darüber und
bislang war es so dass viele der taliban
oder insbesondere die führer versuchen
hier auf den westen zu gehen und zu
sagen so schlimm sind wir noch gar nicht
schlimm aber zumindest nicht an den iran
oder saudi arabien also was wollt ihr
denn schickt uns das geld dann dürfen
auch hefte raus das ist momentan so ein
bisschen die strategie kann man sagen
aber wir werden dann sehen was in ein
paar wochen passiert was in ein paar
monaten passiert und rast ist das wovor
die menschen hier dann ganz große angst
paul wir sehen auch hinter dir an einem
fahrzeug diese weiße fahne der irgendwie
jetzt im ganz kabul offensichtlich
gehisst ist vor wichtigen gebäuden und
wir haben auch zur kenntnis genommen
dass auch viele menschen diese weiße
fahne vor ihren häusern zeigen oder aus
ihren fenstern hängen wofür steht diese
fand
das ist die traditionelle lage der
taliban dies dann eine fahne die steht
für das emirat also das gold ihre landes
klage werden die klassische afghanische
flagge die bis vor wenigen wochen hier
noch bergen hier habe ich nirgendwo mehr
gesehen bislang die wurde abgehängt
überall klaus und du hast nicht jeder
der irgendwie cannes ist so eine fahne
vielleicht doch etwas vorsicht das hilft
natürlich und gleichzeitig ist das so
man fragt sich ob plötzlich all diese
fahrten er kommt wäre die so schnell
produzieren konnte es ist zum einen das
symbolbild des terrors und zum anderen
ist es jetzt das symbolbild der
machtübernahme denn das passiert kracht
und immer noch passiert die übernahme
von einem ministerium die hinter mir die
ministerium für bildung die übernahme
aller aller
des parlaments und so weiter und so fort
all das hätten sich die taliban ist vom
kunden selbst nicht hätten träumen
lassen sagen wir auch immer alle dass es
so schnell gehen würde das die
afghanische armee die sich so ergeben
würde dass der westen das einfach
einfach abhaut damit hätten wir auch
nicht gerechnet wir sind jetzt hinter
mir wieder ein fahrzeug sozusagen
richtung
bildungsministerium farfan will auch
darf
die bahn anhänger oder taliban kämpfer
in diesem auto sind sie komponiert dort
an der schranke
das gebäude nach
außerdem fällt unser blick auf ein
militärfahrzeug in de ja ne art chip der
aussieht als sei er erst vorgestern aus
der fabrik gekommen also sehr sehr sehr
sehr neu was fällt dir auf bei der
ausrüstung der taliban
die geisteshaltung ist aus der steinzeit
aber die waffen scheinen aus der neuzeit
zu sein
absolut klar
auf den moment auf paul und er bewegt
sich schon wieder überbrückt das ganz
kurz paul du hörst du uns glaube ich und
wir hören dich jetzt vermutlich wieder
noch mal die frage von klaus hat die
ausrüstung es ist sozusagen ein modernst
der islamistische armee die es hier
gegeben hat auch nicht vergleichbar
details zum beispiel sie haben hier so
viele warten so viele panzer der telekom
erobern können von den amerikanern dass
einem das angst und bange macht was sie
mit diesen waffen in ein paar jahren
anstellen werden wenn vielleicht aus
afghanistan wieder ein carport an es
wird wenn sie damit versuchen
terroranschläge in europa in den usa
zu vollziehen momentan sagen sie nein es
geht uns allein hier um afghanistan wir
wollen diplomatische beziehung mit euch
aber dafür ist ganz sicherlich keine
sicherheit ganz profane frage zum
abschluss paul wie sind die pläne die du
dir immer moment machst für die nächsten
stunden für die nächsten tage wie gesagt
ganz profan weißt du wo du schläfst
weißt du wo du essen her du kommst weißt
du wo du vielleicht mal deinen hemd
waschen kann es lauter so banale dinge
weißt du wenn du vertrauen kannst in
dieser stadt
ja kann ich vertrauen kann das weiß ich
dass mitarbeiter mit denen wir bei
spielt seit zehn jahren zusammen
arbeiten und die bislang auch alles das
gemacht haben dass viel miteinander
gesprochen haben dass das
allerwichtigste in seinem krisen
kriegsgebiet dass man den menschen
vertrauen kann und das tue ich weiterhin
das merke ich auch dass ich diesen
menschen vertrauen kann also wie oft ich
mein hemd maschen klären das ist mir
eigentlich ziemlich egal ich glaube mit
diesem glaube ich schon sein weil sie
nicht den tag herum weil ich doch nur
ganz wenig mitgenommen habe es gibt ein
paar t-shirts aber darüber denkt man
nicht nach wo wir schlafen ja es gibt
immer noch einzelner safe house des
hotels auf die offen haben man kann
damit übrigens auch nur noch in cash
bezahlen in bar bezahlen weil das
bargeld zum knapp geworden ist dass wir
alle geld brauchen und es ist sozusagen
auch was die lebensmittel angeht sehr
eng geworden ist gibt es spezielle dinge
also wenn man eine karte zum beispiel
sind in einem restaurant ist auch immer
noch geöffnet hat hier dann gibt es
davon weiß ich weiß nichts davon
vielleicht noch bei also man merkt dass
diese hier angekommen ist und dass da
auch noch eine größere auf afghanistan
zu kommen
paul vielen herzlichen dank der
weiterhin gut auf dich auf
[Musik]